foreign
Brook Texas a new planned Community
outside of Austin that Elon Musk is
building for employees at his Tesla
SpaceX and boring companies and this is
Starbase a rocket development site and
another new musk City with housing for
SpaceX employees located outside of
Brownsville Texas recent construction at
both of these sites has led to
speculation that musk is Building
Company towns we think that this big
brother alike control that's associated
with company towns is on America history
shows that that has been a big part of
American industrial history
here's why musk might be looking to the
company Town model for his properties in
Texas
my wife and I bought this property about
10 years ago we originally came for the
the nature and the privacy and the
peacefulness this is Chap Ambrose in
2021 Elon musk's boring company bought
the 70 acre cow pasture that sat below
Ambrose's property I am a fan of Elon
Musk I think a lot of what he does is
really cool and inspiring such a fan in
fact he even owns a remote controlled
cyber truck
but Ambrose quickly soured on his new
neighbors
it's been a radical change since they
moved in there really are building a
shipyard in the middle of a prairie and
that's not all they're building as first
reported in the Wall Street Journal in
March in meetings with landowners and
real estate agents musk and his
employees describe a vision of a Utopia
along the Colorado River
here in Bastrop County approximately 45
minutes outside of Austin SpaceX is
building a 500 000 square foot facility
across the street boring is building a
new Warehouse snail Brook is already
home to some musk employees who live in
modular homes there's also a pool and
Outdoor Sports area and a gym plants
suggest the site will eventually have
110 homes and boring plans to convert
one into a Montessori school as of last
year boring employees could apply for a
home with rents starting at about 800 a
month for two or three bedroom in
snellbrook the median Renton Bastrop is
about twenty two hundred dollars a month
for his part Ambrose welcomes the
economic impact that snellbrook's
residents will bring to the area his
primary concern is how the development
could affect the local groundwater if
you sit out and watch the work they do
they're not careful recently boring
applied to State Environmental
authorities to discharge up to 140 000
gallons of industrial Wastewater A Day
into the Colorado River
since beginning construction boring has
received multiple violations from the
Texas commission on Environmental
Quality
ever since musk's companies moved in
next door Ambrose has been documenting
the development I'm concerned they're
going to continue to to break those
permits I mean they are moving so quick
you know one week to the next it can be
a radical difference musk tweeted that
the March Wall Street Journal article
that broke the news about snail Brook
was false but he has not specified what
in the piece was incorrect furthermore
the idea that musk would create his own
town isn't far-fetched sometimes there's
that new neighbor that everyone can't
stop talking about For Better or For
Worse
in 2021 the billionaire announced he was
building the city of Starbase which musk
envisions becoming a major Spaceport
Starbase is being built on Boca Chica
Village a Seaside Hamlet surrounded by a
wildlife refuge located about 25 miles
outside of the Southeastern Texas city
of Brownsville SpaceX has not officially
Incorporated Starbase but since 2012 the
Aerospace company has been buying up the
area's pre-existing homes and turning
them into employee housing much like
snail Brook starbase's development
attracted scrutiny from residents
concerned that spacex's expansion will
come at a steep price to the local
environment
and what do you get another day older
and deeper in debt in 1947 Country
singer Merle Travis immortalized
exploitative nature of company towns in
his song 16 tons about the life of a
Kentucky coal miner
I almost sold to The Company Store
people tend to think about a town where
the company owns everything where the um
the company has built all the housing
there's a company store and many of
these coal mining towns people were not
paid in American currency they were paid
in company issued money that's really
only good at the company's store author
Hardy green has written extensively
about the history of company towns there
is no strict definition of company town
a company Town there's really only one
company that dominates but beyond that
there's a wide range some towns are more
restrictive more exploited and others
are more caring and paternalistic the
more exploitative company towns like the
one referred to in Travis's song tended
to be communities based around a single
resource whole towns are extractive
industry towns tend to be a little bit
like you know prison camps like snail
Brook and Starbase many of America's
oldest and best known company towns like
Pullman Illinois in Hershey Pennsylvania
were created by wealthy industrialists
who envisioned idyllic communities for
their employees utopian ideals have
figured prominently in a number of
company towns Milton Hershey built his
Chocolate Factory complex in rural
Pennsylvania to attract employees to
what was then a remote location Hershey
constructed a town workers were allowed
to buy the housing they're fairly well
paid the houses are come with Central
Heating and Plumbing but Milton
Hershey's relationship with his
employees soured in 1937 Hershey's
workers organized the company's first
labor union and went on strike
that's a common theme in the history of
many company towns like Hershey Pullman
Illinois was a paternalistic company
town that had housing stores a library
and churches but Pullman like Hershey
eventually ran into trouble in 1894
Pullman cut jobs and wages sparking a
violent worker's strike it started off
being an experiment that the founders
thought would be a kind of paternalistic
place but it didn't work out according
to Green musk's towns somewhat resemble
the paternalistic company towns of old
yeah you could argue that that musk is
employing a kind of a throwback idea of
starting from scratch in an undeveloped
area an undeveloped area that is being
developed quickly even as it is under
the close watch of champ Ambrose we're
not anti-growth we're not anti-elon but
we are pro-clean water and unfortunately
those opposing forces seem to be coming
ahead for some reason
whether snail brook or Starbase will
avoid the pitfalls of previous company
towns remains to be seen neither have
yet been Incorporated so technically
neither exist in a legal sense but if
musk does decide to incorporate either
town that shouldn't be too difficult in
Texas as soon as a community has 201
residents it can petition to incorporate
thank you
[Music]